This is my friend Chris Cross.
That is his name. Yes.
And we get to hear from him tonight,
the same format as the last two weeks.
We have had, uh, Trevor, Al, Dan Lee part.
Now Chris gets to share his testimony, teach a little bit,
and then we'll do the same questions we asked the other two
guys just to keep consistent.
Uh, so I think you can be looking forward to this.
Again, let me just remind you of the schedule, uh,
over the next couple weeks.
If you have any concerns about any of them, come to us
as elders, talk to them as individuals as well.
Just love to kind
of answer any questions you would have if you have some,
but also, uh, we're looking to announce a vote soon
and then move forward in the process towards that.
And again, you're not voting for each
of them, one of them, right?
You're, you're voting for all of them, yes
or no, affirmative, yes or no, not pick your favorite.
So just because Dan had
charts last week doesn't mean like
Vote for Dan. No.
Chart, no.
So, uh, we believe all three are called
by God towards this church.
So I'm gonna pray for you, Chris,
then you let you get going.
Lord, thank you for the opportunity to be together tonight
to, uh, just celebrate your work and our lives.
Get to know one another fellowship around the tables,
but also to, uh, hear what you've done in Chris's life
and walk together as a church toward discerning
what you have for us and for him and his family.
Thank you for him, for Maura, thank you for their kids
and what you've done to bring them to this point.
And we trust you. Lead us going forward.
Encourage us with your word
and with his story for your glory.
In Jesus' name. Amen.
Alright, thank you, John. Um, wow.
So I, I know a lot of you already very well, um,
but there's several in here that I, I don't know at all.
And so I look forward
to getting to know you a little bit more.
Um, hopefully me getting to share my story
lets you know a little bit about me.
And, um, more than anything, what God has done in my life,
um, stories are an incredible thing that we get to share.
Uh, we all have stories about God has, uh, rescued us,
impacted our lives, changed us.
And so it's fun that we get
to share these stories with one another.
Uh, a little bit about my background. I am from Edmond.
I grew up here. Um, I grew up in Henderson Hills, um,
from birth, I mean, just a couple of days
after I was born, my parents
carried me into a green shag carpeted room
where I spent the next 18 years of my childhood.
And, um, growing up
and, uh, learning about who Jesus is, learning the word
learning, uh, how to serve in a church, how to be a part
of community, um, learned a lot
of other really great things at Henderson Hills,
like Gorilla Mangun.
Does anyone know what that is? Any, any youth groupers? Yep.
Um, I learned about pink sequin dresses at Christmas time
and giant Christmas trees with singing heads in them.
Any of those, I think there were like some of y'all
that were the singing heads in the
Christmas tree, if I remember right.
Um, and then other great things that we, I got
to learn at this church, like, um,
man is the three part being.
We talked about that a lot.
Uh, know God, but God and God's church, God's way.
These are all things that are part
of my heritage growing up here at Henderson Hills.
And this has been a wonderful place to be raised in, in,
in the church and God's word.
And God has done incredible things through, uh,
the people at this church.
In fact, it's, it's, um, it's really sweet to be
where I'm at today, talking to you about shepherding.
When I look around this room
and I see people that have shepherded me
so well growing up here, um, how cool
that God does that through his church.
That, um, LaDonna, she always likes to joke about
how she changed my diapers in the nursery,
and she doesn't let me forget that.
But we all have, like, you all have served me,
and now I get to serve you.
It's, it's really beautiful
that God creates his church that way.
Um, so growing up,
my family wasn't the most conventional, you could say.
My mom and dad, they divorced when I was three.
Um, I grew up in a blended family with a stepmom
and, uh, three step siblings.
And then my brother and I, we split split time spending, uh,
weekends and summers at my mom's house
with my mom and my stepdad.
Uh, and while there's a lot
of challenges growing up in a blended family, um,
unique challenges that come along with that,
it was also a very, uh, sweet season of life.
I, I loved growing up in our house with five siblings.
Um, all the trouble that we would get into as kids.
My, my dad did a great job trying to teach us scripture, uh,
teach us wisdom, um, try to share, uh, knowledge
with us about how to avoid mistakes
that he had made in life.
Um, so we had a really good
solid foundation in the word growing up,
and I'm very thankful for that.
Uh, we were very involved in the church.
We are here all the time. Uh, played a lot of hide
and seek in the pews during choir practices.
Um, some of y'all have that experience.
It's a very unique and fun experience if you ever,
uh, grow up in the church.
Um, so a lot of great,
great memories from that season of life.
When I was seven years old, uh, God saved my life.
Uh, Jesus, um, awakened my heart to, um,
know who he was.
My spirit became alive and he saved me.
Uh, I recognized I needed a sinner, and my only hope
and life was Jesus, um, because he had done it all for me.
So I'm very thankful
that he saved my life at seven years old.
Uh, and I was baptized here at the church shortly
after that by one of our elders.
So when I was 13, so fast forward a little bit,
uh, I went through one of the hardest years
of my life at 13,
and it was a year where, um, I really got to know
how destructive sin could be.
So during my 13th year, my second family,
this blended family that I got to grow up in, um,
was torn apart, very much like my first family had been.
Unfortunately, sin had a recurring pattern in our family,
and it led to my dad and my stepmom divorcing.
And suddenly half
of my siblings were no longer in my home during that time.
On top of that, um, shortly
while this was going on, um, one of my brother
and i's best friends decided his life, um,
well not decided, was deceived.
And to think his his life wasn't worth it anything anymore.
And unfortunately, he took his own life
that year at 13 years old.
So, needless to say, during that year, I,
my support system for my family was in shambles
and it was lonely,
and I didn't really know how to make sense of
what was going on or all around me.
Um, I remember a lot of sleepless nights not being able
to sleep, hearing my dad weeping in the next room, um,
as he's dealing with his own heartbreak
and, uh, crying out to the Lord.
Just trying to know why this is happening is,
um, is there any future in this?
Not even know how to do deal with the next, next day.
And God, man, he, he showed up in that year.
Um, when my,
when my parents were emotionally unavailable, God showed up
and it was hard.
But man, what a sweet season,
because I got to, I got to lean into
that relationship in a way that I probably wouldn't have at
that age without those other trials.
Um, he showed me how real
and present he is when no one else in in life was really
present, um, at that time.
And the relationship deepened very quickly, very fast,
and became very real because of that.
So moving forward, I, um,
graduated from high school Saints Pride.
Um, and then I went up to Oklahoma State to go to college.
And man, just like most young college students, my freshman
and sophomore year, um, I did what most college students do.
I live for myself.
And, uh, while I professed, uh, who my savior was,
while I was still a disciple, I didn't act like it.
Um, I pursued things that I was interested in, pursued
and things that were, uh, instantly gratifying for me.
Dating relationships are very selfish.
All of the, you know, all of the things that you do going
through that time of life.
And, uh, I had to learn a lot from it.
God taught me a lot through that season of life as well.
Um, during that season, it was more about recognizing him
as, as Lord and as king,
and am I going to actually submit
to his authority in my life?
And the way he did that was through the church.
He did that through accountability of Christian brothers,
um, some of whom I'm very still very close with today.
Jacob Stockton was one of my roommates in college,
and he was one of those that held me accountable.
And he goes to church here, uh, today,
but also getting involved in a church locally in Stillwater.
Um, God used that.
So by serving in a church, being surrounded in a community
by older believers, uh, that could hold me accountable
and really wake me up to, are you going to live the life
that you profess, uh, that you believe, um,
really caused me to mature, start to mature anyways.
And it's a good thing because my junior year, uh,
of college, I started dating my wife Mara.
And man, I'm glad I was a little bit more mature my junior
year than I was my freshman or sophomore year,
because when you have a beautiful
spirit led purposeful woman like Mara,
um, you don't wanna mess that up.
And God has used this woman in incredible ways in my life
to teach me so much.
And I'm so thankful for Mara.
And as, um, as we grew up together
and, uh, fell deeper in love with each other
and pursued Christ together, we got married shortly
after college.
Um, basically right
after graduating, graduating college, we got married.
And marriage has been an incredibly
refining experience for me.
Um, God has used marriage in incredible ways.
I've got to learn, uh, more about unconditional love
from being married to her.
Uh, the joys of just sharing your life with someone, um,
the, the grease and the good times with her, uh,
has taught me the joy of, um,
serving rather than being served.
This woman serves incredibly well.
If you have the blessing of knowing Mara, you know,
you've been served by her in some way.
Um, but God also taught me a lot about forgiveness, uh,
by being married to, to Mara and his grace shown in Mara.
Um, so when I was,
when I was 13, going back to that year, um, one
of the consequences that came out of
that year is I became addicted to pornography.
Um, it was one of those vices that I think at the time,
uh, allowed some sense of control of what was happening,
or at least a, a way to escape from
what was happening in, in my life at the time.
And unfortunately, it led to an addiction
that carried on all the way into our marriage.
And in that first year of marriage, I remember very clearly
when the, when the spirit convicted me in a church service
here, um, that it was, it was time to confess to her.
And that needed to happen today.
Um, mart had no idea that
that had been going on in my life at
all up until that point.
So at the end of that service, I remember talking with one
of the elders, um,
and he walked me through what that needs to look like.
Um, but he was also very kind
and shepherded me through that.
Um, but it was also very straightforward that
I'm gonna call you in the morning.
I'm gonna, I'm gonna make sure
that you've told your wife last night.
So there was some accountability that I actually had
to do it, and I did.
And it was, man, one
of the hardest nights of my life.
Um, and again, I'm so sorry, Mara.
Um, but God has placed an incredible
woman in my life that, um, forgave me,
um, loved me through it,
and took months, years to rebuild that trust.
And God has been faithful, um, through that.
Um, he's healed me, freed me, used confession of sin
to bring freedom from that addiction, which I'm so thankful
to our God for how he works in us and,
and brings freedom, especially when
things are brought into the light.
So that kind of leads, you know, a lot else happened
besides that in our lives.
But that kind of leads to where I'm at today.
Um, have been able to serve in this church
and grow up, um, more and more by serving in this church.
Uh, we have two kids. My daughter, she is nine years old.
Uh, her name is ela,
and my son is six, and his name is Shepherd.
And man, they keep you humble and, uh,
but life is a lot of fun getting to raise them.
We, we love our kids so much.
Um, in fact, we named both of our kids
after terms in the Bible, um, for, for different re reasons.
Sayah, um, our, our prayer for her is that by her,
that she will, um, take moments in life
and have her life be a, a attempted pause and reflect.
And then with our last name, the cross on the cross
of Christ and Shepherd, obviously, um, we hope
that he grows up to be a servant leader
that leads people towards the cross, uh, in his life.
And he's perked up a lot over the last few weeks
as I've been preparing for tonight,
because every time I say shepherd,
he thinks I'm talking to him.
And I'm really just talking
to myself as we've been preparing.
So, with that, let's get into what we're going
to talk about tonight.
And that's gonna be shepherding like we have the last couple
of nights or couple of weeks.
First of all, I wanna say thank you, Trevor
and Dan for how you've walked us
through this topic over the last few weeks.
And also just thank you for like all, all the,
all the moments we've got to have over the last two years.
Um, church, I am, I love these two men
and I am very excited to see what God is calling them to
and, uh, how they lead so well.
So thank you both.
So Dan, Dan taught us last week on
the elder's responsibility to shepherd by leading
and feeding the flock.
And we spent time talking about particularly what
that means, feeding the flock by teaching the word and,
and delivering the word in a way that that nourishes
and equips the body.
Tonight we're gonna talk about these aspects of eldership
where elders are called to
and have the responsibility to care for
and to protect the people of the church, the flock,
essentially what that, what that looks like is leading the,
the people of God to a place of rest by being present
with them, by providing for them,
and by protecting the flock from threats internal
and external to the flock.
Now, I've, I've never owned sheep. I grew up in Edmond.
Um, so I, I don't know
what this analogy looks like perfectly, um,
but I do own a puppy.
And if you've owned a puppy, uh,
you have tasted a little bit
what sheep probably are like, I'm guessing.
Um, she's adorable.
She's basically like this tiny little potato in our house,
um, with little legs.
This, this little, which basically means she
can't do anything on her own.
Uh, we have to feed her, you know, like they say, the dogs,
um, descended from wolves, even the ones that we own.
I don't, I don't see it when I look at her.
I mean, she's this big and could you imagine like a pack
of little hers running around killing things?
Absolutely not. So she is very dependent on us for food.
She's very dependent on us for watching for hawks.
'cause I'm pretty sure they could just scoop her up.
She's that small. Um, she needs us
to give her a place to stay.
She can't even walk up steps on her own
because her legs are so small.
So she needs us just to pick her up the steps of the house.
So when I try to think about sheep,
I think about her name's Hazel, little Hazel being so,
uh, dependent on us.
Now, when we think about us being referred to
as sheep in the Bible, we may not want think that
that is the most flattering of analogies
or metaphors to use.
Um, but it's, it's pretty accurate when you think about it.
Um, we are very much like sheep when, when it comes to
our spiritual health.
We are prone to wander.
We will eat anything, um, whether it's good
or not spiritually, uh, maybe physically too.
Um, we are defenseless against sin.
We're shortsighted,
and we get sick, we get injured, and we get lost.
Isaiah 53, 6, very common scripture we know says,
all we like sheep have gone astray
and we've turned everyone to his own way.
And the Lord has caused the iniquity of Saul to fall on him.
Ezekiel 35 also reminds us, God says,
and you are my sheep talking to Israel.
He says, you are my sheep, human sheep of my pasture,
and I am your God, declares the Lord God.
So God, God uses that analogy of sheep for us
because he knows what we're like.
He knows that we are, um,
dependent for our care.
And when you think about it,
that's, that's actually a good thing.
Um, because it means he's designed us that way
to intentionally depend upon him for our care.
He did not create us as independent beings
that are self-sufficient.
He ca he created us to be dependent on him.
And that's a good thing. So one of the ways
that God provides for his people in this way is that he
actually partners with other sheep to shepherd his people.
And it's been a pattern that he has used throughout history.
Um, if we think about this in the Old Testament,
the prime example that we all tend to go to
and should go to in the Old Testament is David.
So David is this standard for shepherd leadership
that was set up in the Old Testament.
And so of course we know the stories of David
in his profession as a shepherd.
Um, how he fought lions
and bears, probably tigers, I don't know.
Um, but as his duties as a shepherd.
But he was also,
before he was even made king, he was known as a leader
that shepherded, uh, the people of Israel.
Uh, they speak of him as remaining present with the people
and going in and out with him.
In fact, in two Samuel five, two hear what the words
of the people say about David before he is anointed king.
He said, they said, in times past
when Saul was king over us, it was you who led out
and brought in Israel.
And the Lord said to you, you shall be shepherd
of my people Israel,
and you shall, shall be prince over Israel.
So they recognize
that it was David exemplifying shepherd like qualities even
before he was named king.
And then as king, he carried out his shepherd like duties
by caring for and protecting the people.
He certainly messed up plenty.
We know David's short come comings,
but in his submission to the Lord, he always sought
to lead the people to the source of life.
And that was Yahweh, their provider and their sustainer.
However, unfortunately, if you've read the Old Testament,
you know that this pattern
of shepherd like kings didn't carry on past David.
While we might have glimpses of certain kings that tried to,
uh, follow this standard, the overall pattern
was leading to leadership that did not shepherd well.
In fact, Israel's rulers were selfish,
they were self-absorbed, they were weak, careless,
they were cowardly,
and they were outright rebellious towards God.
However, God is a good shepherd
and he will not leave his people uncared
for and unprotected.
So with that, I want us to turn, if you have a Bible,
will you turn to Ezekiel 34?
I gonna spend a little bit of time here,
and I wanna see how God handles these worthless shepherds
and what he, what he does about it.
Starting in verse one, or sorry, verse two, Ezekiel 34.
This is what God tells Ezekiel.
He says, son of man prophesy against
the shepherds of Israel.
Prophesy and say to them, even to the shepherds,
thus says the Lord God, as shepherds of Israel
who have been feeding yourselves,
should not shepherds feed the sheep.
You eat the fat, you clothe yourselves with the wool,
you slaughter the fat ones,
but you do not feed the sheep the weak.
You have not strengthened the sick,
you have not healed the injured,
you have not bound up the strayed.
You have not brought back the lost. You have not sought.
And with force and harshness, you have ruled them all.
And strong words that God is bringing against these rulers.
So what are the things that they neglected to do?
God calls them out very specifically if looking through
that list, he says, they did not feed the sheep.
They did not strengthen the weak.
They did not heal the sick. They did not bind up.
The injured did not bring back the stray.
And they did not seek out the lost.
And even more so than that, it wasn't just a matter
that they neglected their duties,
but they took advantage of their position.
They, uh, used the people of Israel
for their own gain at the expense of the people
and says they ruled with force and with harshness.
And what was the result of that kind of leadership?
Well, at this time, Israel's an exile.
So they're not in the land that God had led them to.
And it says, if you read a little bit further, it says,
the sheep were scattered, they were lost.
They were hunted down like prey and they were eaten.
Israel had become prey to the surrounding nations.
They wandered and they were often even led
into idol worship.
They oppressed each other.
They took advantage of one another,
and they each did what was right in their own eyes.
So God seeing the state of his people
and this poor leadership declared enough, he was going
to put a stop to it and take the staff away from those
worthless shepherds and take the responsibility back.
So this kind of reminds me of a time growing up.
Uh, when my dad asked me to clean out the shed,
I was probably 11 or 12 years old at the time.
And, um, I had everything I needed to carry out that chore.
He had given me the right tools.
He had set very clear expectations for me, uh,
about what was expected.
In fact, he'd even shown me what the example
of clean looks like.
Um, if you have kids
and you ever, um, told them, this is
what clean actually looks
like, you know what I'm talking about.
So I, I knew what was was expected of me.
However, there was one very big problem
that I was facing in that shed was wasps.
See, I am terrified of wasps like
to an irrational state.
In fact, if you wanna see anyone run as fast as they can
and flail as wildly as I can,
just have a wasp buzz my, my ear.
'cause I'm, I'm going to show a perfect example of that.
I hate wasps. And this shed
of ours probably had a million wasps in it.
Truthfully, it was probably only like one nest
with 10 wasps, but it felt like a million to my 11
or 12-year-old state.
So needless to say,
I didn't do the best job cleaning that shed.
In fact, this is kind of what it looked like.
Um, I didn't pull anything outta the shed to sweep it.
I would open the door
and with my broom, I would kind of run in and do like this
and then run back out and then like run the corner,
run back out as many times as I could just to like,
like look, the first like five feet looked like
it had been swept.
Um, my dad,
after about an hour of this charade,
came out to inspect my work.
And needless to say it was terrible.
Um, and surveying the incompetent work that I had done,
he decided at that point, you know, he's,
he's gonna do it himself.
And so what he did is he came out there
with me watching, showed me how to take care of the wasps.
Um, then he proceeded to walk me through every step
of cleaning out that shed, pulling things out, sweeping out,
putting it all back.
So I knew the right way to do it at that point.
And I think about that 'cause this is where,
this is the point that God is at at this
point with his shepherds.
He says, I'm going to do this myself
and I'm gonna show you what this looks like.
So let's pick this back up in Ezekiel 34, verse 10.
It says, thus says the Lord God, behold,
I am against the shepherds
and I'll acquire my sheep at their hand
and put a stop to their feeding the sheep.
No longer shall the shepherds feed themselves,
I'll rescue my sheep from their mouths
that they may not be food for them.
I read that and the first thing I think of is woe to the man
who the Lord of hosts sets himself against.
I, I don't think there is a more terrifying position
to be in than God saying, I'm against you.
So I say this very, um, with a, with as much weight
as I can that leaders of the church, leaders
of God's people, fathers, husbands,
mothers, all who are called
and commanded to shepherd God's people in some fashion,
we should hear those words and we should tremble in fear.
If in any way we are acting as the leaders of Israel
and taking advantage of God's people,
let us ever be so careful to remember
how incredibly valuable God's people are to him.
So valuable in fact
that God himself will step into the muck.
He will step into the, the pit
and shepherd with us and pull us out.
And that's exactly what we see God do.
Let's pick back up in verse 11.
God says, behold, I I myself will search for my sheep
and we'll seek them out
as a shepherd seeks out his flock when he is among his sheep
that have been scattered.
So will I seek out my sheep
and I'll rescue them from all places
where they have been scattered on a day
of clouds and thick darkness.
He goes on in verse 15, he says,
I myself will be the shepherd of my sheep
and I myself will make them lie down, declares the Lord God.
I will seek the lost and I'll bring back the stray
and I'll bind up the injured and I'll strengthen the weak
and the fat and the strong I will destroy.
I'll feed them injustice.
The Lord God will not leave his people wandering
forever, forever.
Yahweh himself, the one
who redeemed his people from the oppression of Pharaoh,
who led them through the wilderness, providing
for their every need.
He watered them. He fed them with manna.
He healed their wounds from fiery serpents
and he brought them to a land of abundance.
That same God will put a stop to the neglect of his people
and he'll be the good shepherd his sheep
desperately require.
And if we look at what God says he will do,
and we contrast that with what he, the charge
that he brought against the former shepherds,
just look at the contrast.
They did not seek the lost.
And God says, I will search for my sheep
and I will seek them out.
They did not bring back the stray.
And God says he will rescue them from all places
where they have been scattered.
They did not bind up the injured, but God says he will.
They did not heal the sick,
but God says he will make them lie down to rest.
They did not strengthen the weak.
They did not feed the sheep, but God will strengthen them
and he will feed them with good pasture.
And where they took advantage of the people ruling
with harshness, God says that injustice, he
will also destroy the fat and the strong.
So rather than ruling, well promoting justice
among the people, the former shepherds had sought their own
interests and promoted a culture of self-service at the cost
of each other's neighbor.
And unfortunately, when people are left without a shepherd,
without shepherds that exemplify compassion,
self-sacrificial love, generosity, gentleness
and justice, they will deal harshly with each other,
each seeking to protect and preserve their own kingdoms.
And that's what we see Israel, the state
that Israel was in at this time.
Actually the rest of this chapter shows
how God will righteously step in as judge over the sheep
and he will care for them,
but he'll also correct them
from taking advantage of one another.
And then ultimately he declares that he will set up
for them one shepherd, his servant David,
and that he shall feed them.
So if you think about where Israel is at this time in exile,
you can begin to feel a little bit of anticipation
that should have happened from reading a statement like
this, that there is a promise that a shepherd king is coming
that's not gonna act like our kings
that have acted like this for for centuries.
And yet there'll be a king that is gonna come in the line
and in the pattern of David.
David. And he was coming to lead as the Lord himself would.
And if you know your Messianic history, it doesn't take long
for us to make this connection to Jesus, right?
Jesus is the son of David.
He is the Christ, the Messiah, the anointed king
and the rightful king of the Jews.
And he is the good shepherd that God is promising here.
And he says so himself, if we turn over to John 10,
we'll see where Jesus says with his own words, what kind
of shepherd he is.
Starting in verse seven, Jesus says, Jesus says,
I am the door of the sheep.
All who came before me are thieves and robbers.
Remember those is the, the rulers of Israel before,
but the sheep did not listen to them.
I am the door. If anyone enters by me, he'll be saved
and will go in and out and find pasture.
The thief comes only to still steal and kill and destroy.
I came that they may have life and have it abundantly.
I am the good shepherd.
And the good shepherd lays down his life
for the sheep going forward.
In verse 14, he says, I know my own
and my own know me just as the father knows me,
and I know the Father and I lay down my life for the sheep.
So Jesus exemplifies this good shepherd.
And it's not just in word only look at Jesus's life.
And we see how Jesus succeeds,
where all the other shepherds of Israel failed.
Jesus healed the sick, he gave sight to the blind.
He made lame walk.
He reached out
and touched the unclean woman.
He fed literally, uh, the hungry, uh, with food,
but he also fed with the bread of life, words that gave life
to the people he refreshed spiritually, the thirsty
as in the case of the woman at the well.
He sought out the lost in the outcast
and he restored them to the fold thinking about
how he touches the leper and brings him back in.
He calls Matthew a tax collector.
He dines with Zacchaeus one who's seen as a sinner.
He warmly and he tenderly receives the young ones,
the children to himself like a shepherd would with lambs.
He restored hope to the sinful and the broken.
And he gave them rest.
He corrected courageously the ones in error.
He washed the disciple's feet
and he drives out the lurking enemy
and he overthrows the oppressor and he guards
and keeps the sheep safe.
And then ultimately in the greatest act of caring for
and protecting his sheep,
our great shepherd died for us.
He laid down his life for the sheep as he said he would.
And what a good shepherd he is.
And yet this wasn't the end of his service as a shepherd.
Yes, he resurrected, he ascended,
but he carried on his work, shepherding his people
by sending the Holy Spirit
to guide the church, to empower his church.
And then he also raised up shepherds to continue the work
that he did, to continue shepherding in the same pattern
and in the same authority that Jesus himself did.
In fact, he commissions Peter in John 21.
It's a common story. We know Peter
had denied Jesus three times.
And after his resurrection,
Jesus goes out to meet Peter, right?
And as they're talking, Jesus asked Peter three times,
he asks, he asks him, do you love me?
And Peter responds.
He says, yes Lord, you know that I love you.
You know all things, you know that I love you.
And what does Jesus say to him all three times?
He says, then feed my sheep, tend my lambs feed my sheep.
So notice the motivation.
God Jesus is commissioning Peter
to take this responsibility to shepherd.
But the motivation there,
you see the old shepherds failed
and they're tasked to care for and protect the sheep
because they did not have the right motivation.
They did not love God's people as if they were their own.
How could they really?
When you think about it, yeah, this is exactly
what Jesus calls Peter towards.
He says, if you love me, you will do these things.
Love for Jesus, which overflows to love for his sheep,
those whom he valued enough
to purchase at the highest price possible is what
motivates good shepherding.
And Peter, this one who just day bef days
before denied Jesus loved Jesus enough
to shepherd his people as Jesus did.
And that's the example that we see out of his love for Jesus
who first loved him, he would shepherd well his church,
in fact so much, he brings this charge to the other elders,
the other appointees to shepherd
one Peter five, one through five.
He says, so I exhort the elders among you as a fellow elder
and a witness of the sufferings of Christ, as well
as a partaker in the glory that is going to be revealed,
shepherd the flock of God that is among you,
exercising oversight, not under compulsion.
Remember the love motivation, right?
But willingly as God would have you, not for shameful gain,
but eagerly not domineering over those in your charge,
but being examples to the flock.
And when the chief shepherd recognizing
where the source comes from,
when the chief shepherd appears,
you'll receive the unfading crown of glory.
Likewise, you, you who are younger,
be subject to the elders.
And then he says, clothe yourselves, all of you, elders,
shepherds, people of the church.
All of you clothe yourselves
with humility towards one another for God oppose
of the proud, but gives grace to the humble.
So that is the charge of elders to love
as the greatest example.
Jesus Christ, the chief shepherd, love the church to love
and to care for and protect in the same way.
So with that, I, I wanna, I want to end
towards this elders that are in the room.
Will you guys, will you men go ahead and stand up?
Same with you Dan and Trevor.
I know we're, I know we're not elders yet,
but will you go ahead and stand up?
I want us to commit ourselves to love Jesus
by loving this flock.
In this same way. Let's,
let's commit ourselves to these things.
We will commit to care for and protect this flock.
We will commit to feed the hungry.
We will commit to heal the sick and bind up the broken.
We will commit to strengthen the weak.
We will commit to seek out the lost
in search for the strays.
We commit to leading them towards rest.
And we commit to protecting them from any who come to steal,
kill, and destroy by way of false teaching or legalism
or secularism or any other gospel
that is not founded in truth.
And if we do not commit to these things, we have no business
leading the people of God
because they are that valuable to him.
So that is our commitment to this church elder,
you can go ahead and sit back down.
Thank you for doing that in church.
While these men may not be perfect, there is a shepherd
who is, and I want to give you that encouragement.
And one day Revelation seven tells us
that we will all rest under his shepherding.
Revelation seven 15 through 17 says
that therefore they are before the throne of God
and serve him day and night in his temple.
And he sits on the throne,
will shelter them with his presence.
They shall hunger no more, neither thirst anymore.
The sun shall not strike them,
nor any scorching heat for the lamb in the midst
of the throne will be their shepherd
and he will guide them to springs of living water.
And God will wipe away every tear from their eyes
and what of encouragement that we have
that shepherd to look forward to.
So let's go ahead and let's go ahead and pray.
Father, first of all, thank you
for being such a good shepherd towards us.
Thank you for loving us so much that you
would send your son to make a way to have life
with you, to
adopting us into your family for caring
for our every needs individually.
And as a people. God we love you.
We thank you for the example of Jesus.
God, we pray for this church.
We ask that you'll continue in this generation
and the next generation and the next generation to raise up
and appoint shepherds who are
after Jesus's own heart, that love this people well,
that care for them well, that protect them well
and that will lead them and teach them the things that lead
to you, our provider and our sustainer.
And it's in your son's authority
and power that we pray these things.
Amen.
Okay, thank you Jackson. Neil slipped out. So here we are.
Thank you Chris for, uh, sharing boldly, honestly
and for, uh, reminding us as leaders
what the responsibility is we have.
Um, it's a heavy high calling
and so we need the great shepherd to do that.
I wanna just give you a couple opportunities
to answer the questions the other guys already answered.
So if you've been here the last two weeks,
you know what's coming, uh,
but what are ways you've already been involved in
shepherding the people of Henderson Hills since we're
identifying shepherds and trying to then raise them up?
What are ways you've already done that?
Uh, yeah. First
and foremost is with, with my family, with, uh,
my own kids and, and my wife.
Um, that is first
and foremost the greatest responsibility I have of,
of shepherding in God's people.
And I love the call that we have to do that.
Um, but for the last, gosh, I dunno how long, since 2013,
we've been leading community groups here at Henderson Hills.
Uh, we've gone through several iterations of what
that looks like from, uh, home groups
to meeting on Sunday nights to now here at the church.
And that is such a great place to learn how to shepherd
because you're in life with people.
And we've done a lot of life together.
We've had our kids in the community, um,
seen people get married, we've moved, I don't know
how many people we've gotten really good at,
like the whole Tetris situation.
Um, but that has been a, a great place to shepherd.
Other than that, um, I've had the privilege
of being a deacon since 2016 where we've got
to serve this body in numerous ways.
Um, I see Bob Conrad here.
Uh, I think about all the, the times that we've got
to shepherd and you still continue
to shepherd those sweet members of ours
that are over at Veritan
and can't come over here very often anymore.
Um, getting to shepherd
and worship is a wonderful, um, responsibility
and honor that I get to be a part of, um,
and leading people into the worship of our God and Savior.
So love that. And then basically just anywhere else I can
get to hang out with kids at VBS
or student ministry or anything.
Yeah.
So video games weren't all wasted when you talk about
Tetris growing up.
Right. It's helped us learn how to, it's
A very poor life school. Yeah.
Okay. What most excites you about
eldership at Henderson Hills?
Oh, man. Just getting to be a part of what God does,
um, getting to see his kingdom built here
and the role of being an elder.
If that's a, if that's what God is calling me to,
I'm just, I'm, I'm here for it.
I wanna see what God does. I want to see how he uses
this church to go impact the kingdom.
Um, and this, that, that just, man, that fires me up
to see God at work, moving in our, in our body,
in the community here, but then in Edmond
and across the globe.
Um, just, yeah, if God calls me
to be a part of it, I wanna be a part of it.
So it's great.
And, you know, we don't hold back
from the heavy hitters here.
Questions. So what's your favorite ice cream flavor?
Brahms mint chocolate chip. Amen. Yeah.
Anybody? There's a couple. Christine, Brahms, specifically
Brahms. Okay. I mean,
come on, you're from Oklahoma.
It's true. Although my wife's from Dallas,
Bluebell is pretty good.
Let's just be clear. Cookie two step.
By the way, if you haven't had
that, that's straight from heaven.
Uh, what is one of your primary desires
for the church as we move forward?
Man to love Jesus. Um,
and that, that probably sounds cliche,
but that, I mean, that's where it all starts.
If, if we love Jesus, like, like really love Jesus
because we know who he is and we love God
because we see how amazing
and, uh, awe inspiring he is,
God will do amazing things here.
So we'll see that play out in all sorts of ways.
Loving and our neighbors and our community.
We'll see worship that just is, um,
man gives us a taste of what we're gonna do
through eternity.
So yeah, desire for the church is that we just, we fall
in love with who God is as we see him revealed in our lives.